so do you know how terrifying it is when
you're fully asleep closed and then you
wake up naked that's freaky it is freaky
that's a little freaky that's a little
weird
I like to party Jesus honey this is
unwaxed
Sophia and Sistine Salon can we just
become best friends
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwax podcast
with your favorite sisters Sophia and
Sistine
hello everybody happy Tuesday I hope you
guys are all doing
swell having a jolly good day I hope
you're doing so well swell so well
combined by the way I have to say
um now I'm feeling my age and I know I'm
not that old obviously but people are
seeing Riz now and I had to go on Urban
Dictionary to ask what's Riz you haven't
you haven't seen that all over Tick Tock
no okay I think gen Z has formed another
word and it's basically meaning I guess
your confidence your swag your that that
look I don't Rizzle Razzle you know the
in in a sentence they would say
my res can you forward the sentence
please can you spell Riz oh can you use
a sentence so
for example I would say um my res is
better after a couple drinks
like my ribs when I'm sober my wrist
with a couple of drinks like my wrist is
better my confidence is better when I
have a couple drinks I don't get it okay
we totally went off let's do our Wax and
Wane of the week Sophie and I promised
you guys that we're gonna bring back our
OG segments and some new ones yeah and
some new ones so Sophia why don't you
start us with your waxing weight of the
week wax and Wayne if you guys don't
remember are you new here it is highs
and lows okay so my high of the week
this is really interesting I came
downstairs to my wax and I was
so freaked out about my night's rest
because I had Lucid dreamed and for you
guys that don't know what lucid dream is
it's a looser conscious stream that is
one of which you're aware of the fact
that you are dreaming and it's when you
have this dream it seems like your brain
is borderline between REM sleep and
being awake okay
I haven't lucid dreams since I was
probably in elementary school and I
remember the first time I did it was I
was on campus of my elementary school
and I remember walking through in this
stream going why does this feel so real
and I decided to fly and like that
that's weird because normally I feel
like in my dreams I'm just gonna control
what happens in your lucid dreams so
yeah because I feel like if when you
dream normally I don't know if anyone
else this is how their dreams feel they
don't really feel like they have much to
control if people pop up or you can't
yell you can't walk you can't there's
situations where you feel restricted and
I remember
I actually remember be this like as real
as this is right now I felt like that's
how it was my dreams
I kept slapping myself in my dream going
is this real and someone's like yeah
you're dreaming you can do whatever you
want and it was wild and I I think this
was actually way more Lucid than the one
I've had ever had in my life and I
remember talking to someone it was my
girlfriend Maya and I actually hadn't
told her this one that she was my dream
but we were having a conversation
and it was so normal and I remember
feeling velcro next to me being like why
does this feel so real because dreams
are not supposed to feel this real why
are you okay I have a question of all
the things that you can do while you're
dreaming and you're aware that you can
have control of what you do in your
dream you decide to touch Velcro
like I'd be like Jason Momo on my left
kill again Murphy on my right let's have
something but you know what it was I
think no actually not I think I know
when I was in that dream I was so
I was so in my head about what the hell
is going on like it felt like this real
like I think I'm in a dream maybe now
okay thanks
um but I I think I was so like fanatic
and crazy about the fact that this was
happening that I didn't even think about
oh I could literally do whatever I
wanted I think it has something to do
with the fact that we've been
experimenting with a lot of different
melatonin lately gummies drinks and Ice
sometimes thinks that plays the factor
oh yeah yeah and I feel and I know that
um there was one point when I woke up in
the middle of night and I fell back
asleep and I feel like that's when I
start to dream the heaviest is when I
wake up do you ever feel like that when
you go back to sleep at maybe 2 A.M I've
been having the worst sleep cycle ever
so I kind of understand where you're
coming from but do you remember when I
was younger and I used to sleep walk a
lot oh yeah I used to actually sleep
strip
so do you know how terrifying it is when
you're fully asleep closed and then you
wake up naked that's freaky that is
freaky that's a little freaky that's a
little weird Okay so that was your high
of the week that was not that was the
higher of the week and then Wayne is
I've been breaking out constantly and I
know that sounds kind of like breaking
out into dance yes in the Middle Street
I didn't even hear a certain like you're
like pop locking and dropping it yep
dropping it no I I don't know why and
you were saying this is because of
stress and stuff but I've just been more
and you guys are probably looking at me
right now going like where's the acne
for one thing I'm really good at
covering it up two we are blown out and
three I just I'm not that person I'm
luckily you've never had really bad acne
or cystic acne but it's just those deep
ones have just been popping up
everywhere and it's driving me nuts
because I have such an itch to pop
everything and I know when I pop it it's
scars and now I have red dots all over
my face
yeah
so that's my Wayne so pimples pimples on
my way my wax and weight of the week
first of all again this would only
happen to me I just feel like the
weirdest scenarios
just come my way I was walking out of
the gym with Scarlett and we're walking
in the parking lot going to our car and
then all of a sudden I see a strange man
holding a little kitten so my first
instinct isn't oh Stranger Danger Don't
approach the man but instantly when
you're holding a little cat I'm gonna
come up to you because isn't that weird
though like if he was holding like and I
have a box of Cheez-Its who cares but
he's holding a kitten you've got my
attention you know what I found was
weird was the fact that he was wearing
the most absurd suit I've ever seen at
10 A.M okay and you decide let me
approach the weird man and the weird
suit well he had a kid with a kitten he
had a kitten so you know if you're
trying to come up to me hold a cat and I
will come right to you anyway he's
holding this kitten and he goes I'm a
magician
and I go what
he goes yes I'm a professional magician
I've been doing it my whole life I also
just adopted this cat yesterday okay you
guys do you want to see a magic trick I
say sure
because how many times do you meet a
magician in a parking lot so I hold his
cat and he starts doing this whole card
trick and I was like oh wow like I
haven't seen a card trick before but
at the end of the trick
he goes think of
a memory that was when you were really
happy like okay so I thought of a memory
so many how is he gonna know anything
he flips the card over he goes is this
your card
my face is on the card my face is our
photo printed on the card
that's a little weird but do you want to
explain how he knew to print the photo
no don't turn the magic
okay okay so we have to we have to be a
little bit real here the magician the
magician approached my mom and I first I
didn't know and she didn't know this
outside this garage a parking lot and my
mom and I oh and he I guess he
recognized my mom and whatever and was
like really excited we left and then
Sistine Scarlet came out we didn't tell
him about the magician and apparently
within like the hour he adopted Akin and
printed our faces on cards Okay so
it's you know I
this guy truly is Magic because
I think we're being stalked by a
magician now
and I'm not we're not just saying that
lightly he is um you guys are ironically
popping up everywhere the past two days
the past two days we've run into him
seven times
we're at the grocery store he's in the
aisle next to us we're at the mall he's
in he's in the no he's kind of he's
peering I went to go pick up food
yesterday at a random restaurant and he
walks right by the car I go either this
man has a tracking device on me or he
truly is Magic appearing everywhere I am
it's so freaky I don't think he's
actually a magician I'm not sure if
that's okay I think that's just a cover
or Wayne I think it's a ball it's a wax
and Wayne it's like it was a funny wax
and now it's a weird like it's kind of
fun like you're being stalked by a
magician like that and I kept going on
my walk my dad's like you could appear
anywhere and I started laughing because
he's a magician and he's just gonna
Sophia went for a walk yesterday at
night and my dad is so you know if he
thinks it could happen it will so he
just doesn't like anything that would
Aid our safety in any way so spee is
walking alone in the dark which isn't
good no and he freaks out because he
finds out that you're out there alone
yeah he gets on his bike and he starts
biking to find Sophia and my mom and I
are now going on our walk with all the
dogs and we see Sophia sprinting down
the street slide chasing her on a bike
being like The Magician's gonna get you
I mean it was she was so obsessed up
here anyway and I kept laughing because
he's a magician and I was really upset
because he just like gave me so much
[ __ ] about it and yes we should not walk
at night okay my Wayne of the week
I found a bird on the beach
and I said why isn't it flying away
first thought I thought his little legs
were stuck in the sand so I'm like let
me dig them out you know I gotta save
this little guy oh I remember which bird
you're talking about Marty Marty the
Marty the bird so I'm I'm working I'm
digging a hole for him to get out like
I'm trying to save this bird's life but
then I found out when a bird dies it
kind of or when it's in the process of
dying it sort of just Parks itself and
and goes away I think a lot of animals
do that so anyway I tried to get Marty
to fly and then all this like green [ __ ]
started coming out of him I was like I
don't want to get tested so I'm Gonna
Leave Marty so what I did was I planted
him in a beautiful location he had the
sunset in front of him the waves
crashing I said if a bird's gonna go out
let it go out in peace you know what I
mean yeah so my waxes I couldn't save
Marty but you know I think he had a
peaceful death he had a peaceful death
yeah it was sweet you got to listen to
the ocean and the sunset and I know he
had an audience he wasn't alone when he
passed he wasn't alone we were loved it
was a love deeply evil crackers you know
he was a good guy's name and Paulie
Polly want a cracker oh Jesus no okay
let's do a wellness check yeah I feel
like I need a wellness track uh once a
week yeah because it's something I don't
check in on but I think because you know
we're on wax we're gonna be always
pretty honest here and these last few
months have been tough it's not been
easy and I think that Sistine and I we
love this podcast so much because it is
our little break and it's fun and it's
always kind of something that makes me
happy when I leave just because it's a
comedy podcast mostly but I do think
it's important to be honest and like
have that little wellness check and I'm
glad to see created this topic because I
actually do want to ask how are you
doing
not great
not gonna lie to you
um I think
that's not funny I'm sorry yeah you know
what you're such a [ __ ] no but I feel
like I when I deal with uncomfortable
situations I laugh that's my that's my
problem fine fine fine no okay for me I
think it's hard because this year we had
all the these goals and these plans and
we were really looking forward to
a really strong end of the year and a
like jump start into the new year and it
just seems like every single odd has
been stacked against us in our
career-wise our personal life it just
hasn't been easy yeah and something that
I don't ever do is admit when I'm not
okay and be vulnerable and willing to
share to people that I need help or I
need to talk something out so I just let
this anxiety like Fester inside of me
and the carpet is building and then it's
always one day I'll just trip and just
explode with tears and emotions because
I've just been bottling all of this crap
in and I never thought that I had
anxiety and I don't think I did Growing
Up maybe undiagnosed I'm not sure
but I now find myself like my hands are
constantly shaking I stay up till 4am
every night like I can't turn my brain
off and it's just something like weird
learning to cope with I've never tried
you know meditation or I've never tried
journaling or anything that is helping
you know deal with something like that
but it's been
weird I think the hardest part is almost
admitting that you don't need to be
strong all of the time yeah and I try so
hard to be strong for like my family and
my friends and I always want to be the
person that has it all figured out and
has all of the answers and could be the
rock for everyone in the life so that
they can be the balloon I feel like a
lot of people feel like that I feel like
people redirect their emotions on other
things because they don't want to deal
with what is happening in front of them
because any realize at the end of the
day that nothing is actually going to
work out until you figure out how to fix
yourself yes and it has been stressful
and I I'd be shocked if after what has
been happening that you wouldn't have
anxiety it's just been a lot like last
night I just completely
yeah it was a puddle of Tears like I I
couldn't hold it in anymore and it
really did feel good to let it out but I
think something that I really want to
start working on is being more
self-aware yeah because I don't actually
check in with myself enough like you
said I'm so distracted with taking care
of everyone else's problems just to
avoid talking about my own and which
isn't healthy and I've realized that
when you have self-awareness there is no
opponent and you're truly just fighting
against yourself yeah and I actually
wanted to touch on something you said
when you said that you broke down last
night and you felt better after just
doing it and I think a lot of people
need to find that one person that you
can talk to and have absolutely no
judgment from them and have maybe no
words from them depending on what your
style your style of breaking down or if
you want to receive advice or you don't
want to receive advice or as something
like that where you can be
unapologetically broken for a second and
just kind of admit like I'm not okay and
I want to get better but I have to just
get to that point to just say it well
it's also realizing that being
vulnerable and admitting when you're
having a bad day A bad week A bad year
you're not doing well mentally doesn't
change who you are as a person we were
also talking about it on the way here
like sometimes when your environment
just feels so out of control like your
job your friends your family like and
you're trying to piecemeal everything
together and make it all work and
but you're reflecting all of those
negative things that you can't control
as a reflection of who you are as a
person and the two aren't the same you
feel if your environment's out of
control that you're out of control when
it's not you out of control it's your
environment and so that you put it on
yourself and I actually no and I'm happy
that you're opening up about that
because I don't thank the EU last year
would have been as vulnerable yeah and
and what's really important is sometimes
when and I know I'm not the only person
that goes through something like this
but
sometimes when you do feel really down
and out of control
you really do look at it as a reflection
of yourself and you start to question
who you are to the core how you look and
you truly believe that like
people won't like you if you you know
look a certain way or change this or and
that's just not true no it's not true I
mean that's funny you say that because
that's been my problem is overthinking
and I think the way I deal with my
anxiety is I place on other things
whether right now I'm just like hyper
focusing on my hair color or I'm hyper
focusing on my relationship or I'm hyper
focusing on
my body or my career and I I feel like
because my mind is in 400 places other
than maybe what's important and
necessary for me to get back to my
balanced happy go lucky state is
I'm just deflecting and I can't focus on
one thing I I can't get anything done
and I feel just it's just been really
tough because I think the last few
months nothing has been consistent then
especially when you're in this industry
nothing is consistent and everyone
that's an entertainment knows that and
it you can be hot for a year then it can
be cold for five or but then that's also
like a part of everything else in our
lives too not just in our careers so
yeah it's been a lot but this has been
the one thing right now that's giving me
a bit more
of a breather yeah saying like Okay now
I have something I can look forward to
that's consistent you know something I
can go to every week and work on and get
excited about yeah you know actually I
did find this uh quote the other day
about overthinking and I think you would
enjoy it let me pull it up
oh wait wait
okay so I said
people who overthink actually make
better friends overthinking is
associated with empathy the ability to
care for others yeah I do I like I I if
sistine's mad at me or my my mom doesn't
have a cup of coffee I really think
about it and I have to that so that's my
thing is you're you care about people's
feelings I really care about if I can
help someone like I'm like do you need
that do you need that I'll cook for you
I'll do that or like yeah but um yeah
thank you that makes me feel good yeah
everything's a good thing and all in all
feeling sad
doesn't Define who you are and I have to
constantly remind myself of that like if
you make a decision that makes you sad
doesn't mean it was the wrong one
do what makes you happy do what's right
for you don't try to you know make
certain choices to appeal to other
people or to present yourself to others
in a certain way just and I think also
to note feelings are fleeting they're
not a constant
you know one day you can feel like
absolute crap and then hate what's going
on in your surroundings so the next day
you can be like wow this is the luckiest
I've ever been and so remember
they do go away things do change people
come into your life you discover
something new and it can completely flip
your world around in one second so wow
look at us are we a therapy podcast
I like it we're wow okay let's let's
pick up the pace a little bit okay so I
was having this conversation with Sophia
yesterday and I said holy jingle balls
Christmas is literally around the corner
I am sitting next to Scrooge I try to
play Christmas music on the way here I
think the last time we were shooting
this episode and she goes no I want to
change it it's annoying I don't like it
All I Want For Christmas Is You Mariah
Carey she turned it off that song the
song the holiday song unpopular opinion
Mariah Carey is not the queen of
Christmas she's just not if I was gonna
pick anyone it'd be Michael Buble sorry
sorry that's fair you know even like
Kelly Clarkson you know who's underrated
who and you guys should check out her
album for Christmas it's Tori Kelly
nice
vocals and she has her own songs and
they're so good 25th I think that's one
of her songs I've been listening I've
been listening to all my walks I'm that
person we're so different I'm the person
November 1st we are holly jolly in the
mood it is I also read something about
with if you celebrate Christmas before
way before it even happens starting in
November that means you have trouble
staying in the present and you'd rather
fast forward through life Jesus
what no it just means I want to have I'm
full of quotes to them no so this is a
thing she it's like she loves Halloween
she starts playing for Halloween
the day after Halloween oh literally
she'll she'll decorate for Halloween
three months before but for me it's it's
just you know what it is I think I
actually don't disagree with you I think
people that love the holiday season love
nostalgic things yeah like I love the
cheesy Traditions I will absolutely
trust my kids in matching onesies and
we'll watch the same holiday film every
single year by the fire by a Christmas
tree like that's who I am see Sophia's
version of Christmas is putting on the
fuzzy socks drinking some hot cocoa by
the fire watching the holiday oh my God
Cameron Diaz by the way the only reason
that movie is good is because Jack Black
is in it period Point Blank um you no no
you've got this man no there's no no no
no listen let me play it when's lit
there's no Jack Black there's Cameron
Diaz No but I'm sorry the really cute
one that we he was in Talented Mr Ripley
Jude Law
you can't tell me that's not an All-Star
cat but I'll tell you what why just Jack
Black being it makes the film because
everyone else in that movie it makes
sense they all look like Christmas type
characters you've got the School of Rock
and Nacho Libre in a Christmas rom-com
but yeah and it works like that's
incredible do you want to hear something
funny I just watched an interview with
Jack Black and he was talking about the
holiday and he was saying how he didn't
think he would actually get this wrong
okay so he's like why would I play
exactly he Winslet's counterpart
um and be like her lover in it but they
hired him and he's like all right I
gotta do it but it broke it up but
that's why it's such a good movie Four
Christmases is a great movie see my
alone my favorite Christmas movie is The
Nightmare Before Christmas
because she loves Halloween Scrooge Who
Says like The Nightmare Before Christmas
during the holidays I like that's like
saying you like Coraline
um on New Year's Coraline's [ __ ] up
Caroline Coraline's crazy but you know
what I've realized as you get older
Christmas completely changes because you
just have those
such sweet cute memories when you're a
kid and you're right like running up to
the tree and you believe Santa is real
which she is
not so he's not
but what excites me about the holidays
is Black Friday and that is maturing no
think about it did you give a [ __ ] about
a Black Friday deal like two three years
I still don't give a [ __ ] about cyber
monday is like wake me up in the morning
done I'm there on the computer ordering
everything I don't need that is
Christmas to me me I'm already ordering
my holiday dresses I'm trying to think
about how to make some muled wine if
anyone doesn't know what that is is it a
mulled wine malt is it
Moscow mule I also love a Moscow Mule um
mulled wine and then
um I'm also thinking about stocking
gifts to give you guys and also
Christmas gifts but listen the holidays
are freaking stressful no yes they are
they're great it's so so Sophia yeah
you need someone impregnate her she
needs to be a mother ASAP with little
babies you need footie pajamas you need
butt flaps on the flannels you need all
of that I'm talking like
you can't tell me the Gathering of all
of the families isn't just sometimes so
overwhelming and stressful but I would
rather
that in a holiday festive attire with
like snow and trees and little like
tinsel and uh what's it called um the
kissing
mistletoe mistletoe have you ever
actually kissed anyone under a missile
no I haven't
no you have yeah I have was it cute
think about it it wasn't cute it was on
a fishing rod
what I was at a party was it oh was it
during like a holiday thing or was this
like a July I think it was like October
but we are very different when it comes
to the holidays and I think it is
stressful it is stressful because there
is like four holidays that come into one
it's first it's Halloween then it turns
into Christmas Eve then it's Christmas
and then it's Thanksgiving and then it's
I am New Year's The Best Gift Giver
Point Blank
you didn't like my gift last year no
because it was fine two years ago yeah
she got me a Squatty Potty
I really was the Grinch on Christmas
because I got Sophia Squatty Potty I got
her like tickets to go do like a really
fun pizza making that's such [ __ ]
you got me tickets to Ratatouille no I
didn't did that and then she lost the
tickets oh yeah she did
and she's gonna find the emails I got
Sophia uh a Squatty Potty for Christmas
because I'm like first of all they're
fun good for your health your bowels
that's the gift that keeps on giving
look I I can say that's why potty is now
like a fine thing to have but at the
time you're so mad I know I I'm not good
at gift giving I'm good at like
experience giving I know I must I'm not
even gonna say the one I got to my mom
because I thought it was funny and she
got so mad at me it was basically a gift
to remind people of like
I got Sly underwear that said skid marks
on the back yeah you you give yeah her
got gifts are kind of weird they're like
yeah didn't you give me underwear with
like Maple's face on it or something but
like that's our cat
we have we're so blessed to have so much
it's like why not just have a good laugh
well that's why
has no price tag it's the best medicine
it's the hottest thing someone can do is
make you laugh no I'm excited about it
and I can't wait for our like holiday
parties to go to and you know like
cuddle by the fire and you're not
cuddling with me
fine I'll cuddle with Buster Buster will
cuddle with me oh one you're something
funny speaking of death we drove by a
graveyard speaking of death no we drove
by a graveyard today and we were just
saying how we wanted to go walk around
it I know it's an unpopular opinion but
I truly believe cemeteries are beautiful
I think they are beautiful
perfect date picnic in a cemetery I'm
sorry I would Swoon I would Swoon
because you're not alone you have
company it's not awkward if
tell me this if a guy on the first date
came up to and says hey I'm taking you
to a cemetery you would run the other
way and you wouldn't that would be on me
stassi Schroeder got engaged proposed to
at a cemetery she's a reality star and
also but you didn't take her on a date
to a celebratory until like three years
into dating
so anyway
but we started having this debate in the
car well I first questioned Sophia and
Scarlett I said
just a random quirky thought would you
rather be buried or cremated and I think
that's a big debate because some people
um I want to become a tree
I want to be a tree so squirrels can
like nut in you and literally kids into
your world I'm going to be this giant
giant sycamore tree or pine tree in a
forest and you can just you mix me with
the little thing and then I grow and
what kind of tree would you want to be I
just told you or like a maple tree no I
just said Pine or Sycamore not a palm
tree
I would definitely this is plaque this
is Sophia so if he wants me a tree but I
said
we all came to the agreement that we
want to be buried and I was like okay
well would we want to have our coffins
next to each other how do we want to do
this in Sophia goes I have a good idea
how about whoever dies first obviously
gets buried first and whoever dies next
gets stacked on top so we're all this
together so we're not lonely so this is
the thing I don't want to be in my own
coffin that's scary and I don't want to
be like just like next to them because
I'm gonna be in the dark oh this kind of
sucks I'm gonna walk around like people
walking around here how fun would it be
if we were just like it's like a
sleepover fraternity oh now we're I was
thinking I'm like okay if we if we
decided to stack each other on top
obviously I want to die last but I'm the
oldest so I have to figure out how to
outlive Sistine and Scarlet because I
don't want to be the one that's on the
bottom and then be smashed on top of the
other two yeah that would suck well we
also agreed we'd bring snacks we did say
we'd bring snacks and Scarlett said what
was that like in and out
how smelly is in and out after like an
hour of eating and then out in your car
it's horrible I mean it tastes great but
it's forget it forget it I said I said
saltine crackers what did I say I love a
little soup cracker oh I bring some like
good almond butter
some people it's almond butter how about
where are you gonna wash your hands
sticky by the way sticky sticky all the
worms are gonna get I'm sorry who wants
to eat Saltines when you're definitely
going on the bottom because I can't
stand the thing if you're on top of me
and you're gonna drip that [ __ ] on me
you're going on the bottom no for sure
then you're gonna be crunching on salt
teeth it's gonna get in my eyes
you're already dead no you're dead you
know I'm just another company no it
smells gonna be the worst because she's
gonna probably be the one on top and she
doesn't bring something that is just so
watch her bring this like Sriracha chips
there's like Sriracha cheese puffs I
would bring like Takis yeah Takis I
actually like red fingerprints
everywhere oh God oh my God can we talk
about White Lotus okay
did you want to say something else yeah
I had another comment okay say your
comment I thought that we shouldn't be
in a coffin we should be in a time
capsule
so people can open us up so think
picture this picture this I don't know
who would care to open our our coffin up
but it's a time capsule so we're all in
there we're all mummified so we can look
like pretty legit right like we'll have
we'll put some like
eyes and a smile on my face Tanner and
some lashes well no no we're gonna be
mummified so I'm gonna get someone to
have Sharpie and just like put two holes
in a smiley face like or like we could
put Scarlets sad or it's very funny like
so like like we can do Emojis on our
faces but then I thought it'd be
interesting to do a time capsule and I
would bring all my journals so people
can read everything I've been feeling
fast
you put journals maybe maybe journals or
maybe like a like a jewelry piece that I
really like and it can be a very much a
big value
I just put like my weave in there or
something or maybe do I make like a
little oh I have an idea I have an idea
we make a USB device of all of our
unboxed episodes and we say uh put in if
you dare and make it look scary so all
these scientists are around us and they
put it in it's just I think you better
start digging you have this [ __ ] figured
out already I'm like I think that'd be a
great weave maybe a vibrator let's
confuse them in the year 5000 everyone's
gonna be watching on wax and then we're
gonna be the biggest stars and then
somehow they're gonna figure out how to
use crispr recreate our little DNA genes
and then create us again and then we can
do this all over again but maybe
with
a really cool lifestyle I don't know
what the what's gonna happen in the year
5000 but
right
so what were you saying about like White
Lotus
get my eye yeah I don't know what
tangent you just went on but we'll
continue I have a lot of thoughts going
on in my head so Sophie and I have been
watching season two of White Lotus first
thought Jennifer Coolidge incredible
actually
we're sitting with Jennifer coolidge's
stunt double
take it away makes
me I thought that was going to be better
I I can't do it on this one come on do
it
um
it looks like it looks like the Fourth
of July like [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] up
you just make it too quiet
um uh what's another one
um I'm taking the dog dumbass
all right it's not bad for just I
haven't done it in like a long time okay
so if you guys haven't watched season
two we're in the thick of it and
um the first episode
Mr James uh no what's his name Mr Theo
James Mr James sober oh yeah the new
team
yeah was that real he had a willy on
camera and my first thought was boing
but my second thought was finally do you
know what I mean I feel like every show
every movie we watch it's always women
naked and the guys are never naked right
and so yeah no to reverse the rules a
little bit except you know I saw an
article that it was a prosthetic
yeah I did see that too so my question
remember that show sex life that was on
Netflix and that was was that real was
that a prosthetic I feel like a lot of
people actors do that now but that's
fair I guess would you do a nude scene
never
why never put a price on it
10 billion dollars
wow 10 billion dollars no 20 billion
dollars
that shit's not going anywhere I would
have done it for weightless she's like a
whopping six dollars it's like four
dollars
bag of peanuts and four dollars no I
would I wouldn't buy your Saltines and
two dollars I wouldn't say no
but I guess Tastefully
when it's artistic and it's done by HBO
yeah when it's like classy you know what
I mean it's like a little bit wait so
how much would you
do it for you know what I think about
all the time how much these girls make
on only fans
they make a lot of money we'd make a lot
of money no they're making like 50 to
over a hundred thousand dollars a month
yeah I I don't know but but think about
what you're do I mean look no shade no
shade to anyone that does it I don't
want to get jealous
I don't want to get hit on for like
whatever but I just don't know if I
could do that I still I still just don't
I don't know what about selling your
feet people would love those little
claws you give my feet so much [ __ ] so
you Got Fingered you got finger toes you
got some finger toes why is space so big
between your toes why is your hands so
big they look like they can be that's
our base Summits that's our Niche that's
our thing you do the foot picks I'll do
the hand picks does anyone have a hand
fetish
yeah I'm sure someone out there has a
hand fetish like please don't tell me
who you are we don't really want to know
um but speaking of other things we can
do with our lives I want to talk about
something I'm really excited about and
it has been really fun um and I wasn't
gonna talk about it because I haven't
really finished anything yet but
I'm writing a book
whoa whoa no um so if you guys know I
have my book club and I've been a big
big reader very Avid Reader yeah it's
called favorite book club on Instagram
um and I do some recommendations on Tick
Tock too if you guys want to check that
out but I have just been a very very big
book lover I've done it since I was
little or done it I've been reading a
ton since I was little it was my Escape
everything in life and I decided to make
a book club but then
as I was growing up I always loved
writing and um I don't really know where
the decision came from but I thought why
don't I actually try I don't I think it
was one of the situations where I just
didn't think I could I'm so proud of you
for this because you are your biggest
enemy anything you want to do you feel
like you can't accomplish it for some
reason but then you look at everyone
else doing those things and why do they
get to do this is the funny thing it's
one it's my overthinking I think a lot
of the times when I want to pursue
something new which is a lot of people
that try to start something now I didn't
I mean I started young but I wasn't like
everybody else that was trying to be a
writer they were writing for like they
were going to English for college and
they were writing short stories a ton
when they were younger until growing up
and it was like they're everything and
not trying to say like I could just take
this up and see if I can do it but I
mean I feel like I could I love writing
I I mean I write every single day and I
read every single morning noon and night
if I ask some questions yeah sure
so what genre is your book going to be
well right now it's kind of a cross
between historical fantasy romance and
fiction type thing yeah so all of them
yeah but this is the problem I'm also
I'm doing two different books at the
same time because I feel like I can't
focus on one multi-tasker which is not
the best idea because I feel like I'm
okay so is anything based off of your
life
no oh uh I mean you write what you know
yeah not really I guess I would say the
character in the first book so the book
is based on a girl that lives in New
York City and
um she it's I I feel like I shouldn't
say it it's one of those situations
where you know you want to say it but
you can't really say it because you
don't give a little sleep but it's it it
flips time periods from like the 1920s
to now in New York City that's cool
which is really fun and there's a lot of
research then from that yeah and one
thing I didn't realize going into this
process which is I mean anything you
start new you're going to be learning
along the way is and my dad's been
telling me this since I was younger and
is that writing is the toughest part of
the process finding that time to sit
down and get your words out without and
also not judging everything you write is
impossible I feel like I'm I'm pretty
consistent with it and I try to not go
back which I do a lot and edit
everything because it's not you know
sometimes when I'm saying these things I
can edit and take it out but these are
my words and my thoughts and you know to
not judge it doesn't have to be perfect
it does have to be perfect and that's
right yeah and so is writer's block a
real thing oh 100 and that's why I
started the other book is because I
didn't want to stop writing but I
decided to divert and write something
that maybe I'm more passionate about or
more excited about so I didn't stop that
flow but I'm really excited I mean I
look
if anything happens with this
um I just hope I get it done and that it
gets published and it literally can be
the most unread book in the world well
how far along are you I'm like I would
say there's three parts to it and I'm
almost I'm starting to hit the second
part so which is yeah which is pretty
good I know she won't actually let me
read anything I I gave her like the
intro a little bit why because I I it's
what I can't let you read my work you I
gave you my script yeah I know I read
the first few pages it's good the first
few pages I have to get into it more so
so no not in a bad way it's a lot it's a
script it's a long script I just keep
reading and then it takes about 45
minutes to read I know I'll sit and read
the whole thing actually I did by the
way I promise you I did think about this
the other day also she's so descriptive
and she wrote a script and it's gonna be
coming out and shooting next year I
really want to put Scarlett in it you
should you should I mean why not why not
why not but see that's another thing did
you ever think that you could be a
producer or write a script no no and I
mean this is and you also it took years
to get to this point like it wasn't just
something that just worked overnight and
I think that's something I need to work
on is not expecting things just to click
and be perfect people spend years
writing yeah people oh yeah I know and
I'm my goal is to finish it by next year
and it would be a dream to be an author
I I mean there's something I see that
for you I would love nothing more to be
I mean like I love to leave the house
and things like this and do that but I
would love to just be able to write from
home and like write things I'm
passionate about then people like my
work and so I'll be the person pushing
you to continue it yeah I do need some
motivation because as everyone else our
unwaxers accountable for you too yeah
please please motivate me so well and
give me writing tips that you do I would
love it honestly if anyone is a writer
or has has been a writer before and like
telling me it'd be good even to share it
here if like any production like
productive tips or writing styles or
ways to get out of writer's block and
stop judging yourself good for you it
would be very helpful so while you're
gonna be at home this weekend being
extra productive about your book and
your writing
my Alter Ego was coming out this weekend
we hope
Tina
is coming out to play Tina Tina and if
anyone knows who Tina is Tina is the
alter ego of sustained Bambi my drunk
Alter Ego yeah she hardly comes up but
when she does it is a blast here's the
thing
I remember last episode I said to you
guys I'm not fun I don't go out I need
to loosen up a little bit right yes
Scarlett is taking me under her Wing
this weekend and she goes I'm bringing
you out for a bender in Miami
first thought terrified
second thought I have nothing to wear
because the clothes in Miami are just
well Scarlet's just close to nothing
because look Scarlett knows the places
to go can she go no but she knows the
place literally is like the king of
Miami she knows what it goes everyone
there she knows everyone she's a little
hustler that one yeah so I'm really
excited I feel like I need to get my
mojo back well I have a question why do
you think that you're going to be able
to do it now because Cecilia has a
really hard time drinking and and that's
not a thing where I'm don't come at me
saying don't force her to she's been
saying she wants to but she has a hard
time like just like I overthink things
going out
I have alcohol guilt and anxiety
will have so I just feel like I can't
because I think maybe it's because I'm
wound up so tight that if I loosen up
with some liquor my guard will go down
I'll get a little silly and there's
nothing wrong with that so I just need
to push myself just to have a little bit
more fun yeah and not be like there's a
pull up my ass can I give you some
advice sure to like start I mean look
you are going to be thrown in the deep
end like you're kind of with Scarlet you
have baby floaters on barely that have
been popped and you're going in the deep
end but what I would say if you're
having anxiety or just guilt drinking
one thing that I would say that helps is
to start doing it going to dinner and
just having two glasses of wine on a
Wednesday
do you see what I'm saying like having a
cocktail on a Tuesday okay things like
that I'm just saying in general because
look you're gonna do what you're gonna
do this weekend and I God forbid bless
yourself I don't know how I look I I
can't go back I actually want to come
back with some amazing stories I want to
come back with like dirty feet and a
missing nail and just good content is
that why I'm hearing Paulie D from my
bedroom wall I've been gym tan launching
I've been watching so much Jersey Shore
I figured take some tips from the ocean
how many times have you watched the
entire Seasons all the way through I
want to say three or four four but it
never gets old it never gets old and if
I'm gonna learn how to party from anyone
it's going to be Snooki
and so I've been gym tanning laundry
every day this week I'm ready to go
you're getting my mojo back I'm putting
some pep in my step I'm ready to rock
I won't believe it when I say I actually
don't think you're gonna get to that
level I even want to be a little bit
toxic
like toxic like past us toxic
I want to ruffle some feathers
why did I do that last night but
whatever are you nervous no
yes I know you're nervous because you're
going with your friends that they they
know how to go out uh but I think it'll
be fine I think I need to add some new
red flags to my list start checking some
things off do you have any new red flags
it doesn't that it's just a general you
know what that's that's actually a good
question is there anything that I've had
this year come up that would be
considered red flags for people to be
warned about me
um I sleep like a vampire
I always find myself with my arms
crossed like this on my chest and I'm
probably sitting up at about 45 degree
angle weird I know why
I don't know comfortable naked sometimes
I don't know what else
um
everyone says I chew like a cow well
that's yeah that's been that's been a
constant problem my jaw goes in like a
360 yeah
so ugly
um oh I noticed this yesterday
I've been taking so much biotin this
sounds insane so much biotin that the
hair on my face grows
I look like a billy guy I thought that
makes sense because she bought face
Shapers the other day
you're gonna out me like
five minutes everywhere dirty little
gerbil you're gonna out me like that
do you have a little stash okay I did
yesterday but it's so crazy because
sometimes okay I feel like women might
understand this you just wake up and you
just get like a prehistoric like
chin hair and you're like how was that
not there yesterday I know I look like a
little billy goat I'm like what is going
on chill with the biotin your hair is
look at her hair it's long enough no oh
my Lord do you have any
um
um okay
oh I I have I can't hear anything duh I
swear no it's the same things it's
selective hearing it is selected I'm
sorry you don't listen to me I think my
hearing is gone it's actually the rudest
thing ever because I'll tell you
something I'll give you instructions
I'll like ask for your help to cook or
something and you literally do not
listen and I go okay never mind but then
you heard my sass
and then you're like what never mind
what and you're ready to score up no
because my phone told me that my
exposure to volume has been increasingly
um
worrisome because I listen to music way
too loud and I think I'm actually losing
my hearing so you're probably gonna hear
me say what 400 times a day and I'm
really bad at texting people back I
think that's contribution to the anxiety
I've been feeling I just read it and I
leave it I think that's the rudest thing
ever I don't know I know I know and then
I just forget to do it and then I go
[ __ ] like I'm so sorry I spaced out and
I know oh I hope my friends don't hear
that because I say that a lot and um but
I don't mean to so not texting and um
also I can't decide anything in my life
I have been flipping back and forth 24
7. I can't right now the trend I said
this in the beginning is my hair I okay
she walks into the kitchen the other day
she bought a bottle of brown hairspray
it was um dry shampoo and she comes into
the kitchen I literally was like didn't
even recognize her I gasped
you were full brunette I was her color
I was literally sistine's color that
dark
and find your own look I love it find
your loved it no no no so how's that
I I don't know if this is like because I
I'm needing something drastic to change
in my life and that now I'm just thick
like fixating on my hair but I want to
go Brown like I want to go Brown I think
everyone's going back to their natural I
mean as you can see you want to go Brown
Wait I'm gonna write a book I'm gonna
write a book
you don't own the color brown and by the
way fine write a book okay
smut
I don't want to sell one is sex and buck
by the way I'm gonna sell more than you
and also why don't we ask them why don't
we ask the unwaxes should Sophia go
brunette yeah my mom loved it and all my
friends really liked it when I sent them
a photo the only person didn't like it
is
that person right there I've had blonde
hair for a while and I think just like
you you wanted a shift and I know that
everyone says if you go Brown It's Gonna
it's really hard to get your blondes
back and it'll be definitely a slower
process but I think I'm ready and it's
fall everyone's going back to their
natural color and also if anyone knows
about being a blonde and having to dye
your hair every four to six weeks your
hair fries off I'm lucky enough thick
hair twins no I'm not going it uses us
as twins yeah I'm putting highlights in
my hair I'm not your solid color brown
you're like our OG color but me I
couldn't go that dark I feel like I
would I would look like Wednesday so
you're constantly trying to change your
aesthetic that's your record yes
I might get bangs
but I'll tell you I think I should get
bangs has an arch nemesis what
a gust of wind
think about it because it blows you got
they go to the side you look like Urkel
come on yeah I actually didn't even
think about that I know I know that
sounds like a good luck I know don't do
it I don't think you do it I think bangs
are scarier should we get into some
unsolicited advice
um I'm so excited to get back into
unsolicited advice we used to do it
every single week and this time we used
to we just asked in our stories a
question but actually this time if you
want your question answered please go to
Apple podcast go to our page give us
that five stars and then write your
questions there we also love when you
guys write little tidbits about what you
like about the show and they read all of
them yeah we read all of them so just do
that and I promise you we've actually
probably answered every single one of
them and we will come to yours here are
two and let's get into it
this person wrote In
should you wait to be approached or be
the approacher
now I loved this question this one stood
out to me in terms of dating yes okay
I always say
if you put yourself out there what's the
worst that could happen they could come
back and say I have a girlfriend or
boyfriend you're not my type I'm not
interested it doesn't hurt your ego that
bad
but if the outcome is they possibly
reciprocate and are into you the why not
take that step and just go for it yeah
it's not that scary you know I just had
a thought come up right now and it's
funny that people have been asking this
a lot I think this question has always
been one how do I approach a guy or how
do I approach a girl this and that and I
feel like dating apps have really
hindered us for having the confidence to
go up to someone because we never had to
worry about that we always were able to
well we didn't have an option we had if
we wanted to meet someone if we wanted
to meet someone's friend you still had
to approach them and that was the way of
dating and getting someone's number and
now with dating apps as just sort of
like a wall yeah it's a third man in the
middle of the middleman between having
to do that approaching without actually
seeing them in person
um my also
when you're messaging on an app or
texting or whatever how you're
however you're communicating on the
phone
I've often found and have so many
girlfriends that can agree with this
that your texting game can be so strong
and witty but the way you vocalize in
person is a zero
it's different that's why I look I don't
think dating apps are a bad thing I know
this is not even the question but I do
think it's really important to have that
confidence to still go up to someone and
approach them yeah be the approacher
because I'll tell you I have done it
before and it works and I'm not saying
that look I'm not saying oh yeah it's
easy to do it but I also don't think
that there's really much weight to it if
it works it works it doesn't it doesn't
why you get it's ignored like okay but
it's not that serious and it doesn't
have to feel like utter rejection if
they're not into you I also think when
you're approaching someone why are you
putting why are you making it so heavy
you're just talking to someone it's not
you're not marrying them you're just
catching the vibe and by the way she
said catching a Vibe and you also could
approach them and not even like them so
I think just we have One Life to Live
approach someone because it could be
your husband your wife or
dating only happens if you put yourself
out there to do it yeah so next question
Sophia what do you make of a guy that
watches your stories Non-Stop
I feel like you can
go off this one
you know it's that's tough because if
it's if it's someone that you were
dating and it's next and they've been
watching your stories a lot then they're
definitely checking in on you I mean
that's pretty obvious all right so I
asked my guy friend this question
and I said do guys check their stories
to see you watched it or is that just a
female thing because I feel like
typically women
are checking to see you looked at it and
more than guys
they told me never
they never do it they don't care they
don't care
I think that they don't notice can I be
honest I think they really
don't care when a guy looks at a story I
don't really think they're putting that
much thought into it unless you're an ex
I think that that's a different
situation but if it's a guy that likes
you I really am not thinking that I
they're probably clicking through
stories and yours just happen to be
there I know I'm not trying to like
deflate someone's confidence I've had it
both ways where I was like oh my God
this guy that I like is always watching
my stories
he likes what I'm posting whatever
and then I've had the opposite too
so if he's only watching your stories
and not really taking any other steps to
confirm to you that he is interested
then I would just say he's watching your
stories yeah that exactly I think women
are a little bit more methodical with
that stuff than men are but let's not
get it twisted y'all
if you don't think I have a close
friends with a strategic close friends
list
for strategically planting people to
look at my stories in a strategic way I
actually thought this is genius I didn't
think about this you guys this is my
little hack I want to share and then
we'll wrap up
okay so say if you posted a general
public Instagram story and maybe you
looked cute it was a selfie it was a
photo of your pasta I don't know and you
want to see who watched it as a specific
person we'll say and you can't find it
with the list of your friends that have
watched it right after
have that person in your close friends
list on Instagram post a close friend's
story of literally anything like it
could be your toe literally anything
that way you can see exactly if they
watched the first one or not that's a
good one or or you just post really
really fire ones in your close friends
for just the people that you want to
show it off to
no is that is yours is what you meant by
that well knife I mean you have a close
friends unless you add let's say if
you're I'm speaking about guys if you
wanted to add all the guys you like just
oh no that's what I do yeah that's what
I'm saying
yeah and you just do it for that
specifically toxic no genius absolutely
I think we can wrap it up there yeah I
liked this episode this is fun you guys
tell us what you want we really want to
have more listener involvement into the
show we want to make you guys a part of
it and feel like you're being heard so
if you want us to talk more about a
certain subject if you want us to talk
less about a certain subject yeah please
I mean if you like the mental Wellness
check-ins if you like
um the unsolicited advice if you like
the bedtime stories or even I have we
were going to do one today but we're not
but like even just us talking about
studies that we found and things like
that let us know
um yeah we can hear you so we hear you
let you know how Miami goes kiddos
we will see you next Tuesday
[Music]